Nouvelle bataille, nouvelle victoire.
Aujourd'hui, au Parlement européen, nous avons voté,
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler,
1 texte qui concerne les permis de conduire.
C'est notre collègue des verts françaises
Karim Adeli qui portait
cet agenda de contraintes absolument improbables.
La 1ère version du texte prévoyait de créer
1 interdiction pour les jeunes
conducteurs de rouler la nuit
ou bien des permis spéciaux pour conduire des SUV.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons voté 1 texte qui,
grâce aux amendements que nous avions déposé,
avait déjà été largement rééquilibré.
Et pourtant
il contenait encore des dispositions inquiétantes.
Les élus macronistes ont voté
par exemple en faveur de la création d'une contrainte,
1 examen médical régulier pour avoir gardé son permis.
Nous nous y sommes opposés et nous avons gagné
cette bataille.
Nous avons aussi trouvé
1 accord pour empêcher la création d'un permis
spécifique pour les tracteurs
qui auraient compliqué la vie de nos agriculteurs.
Malheureusement,
le Rassemblement National a voté contre la solution
que nous avions trouvé
à la fin. Le texte est passé malgré notre opposition,
mais il ne contient plus rien
qui pourrait constituer 1 problème majeur.
Je crois que nous aurons éviter le pire.